let's talk about the music and
off-the-menu you have a composer that
you hired yeah gentleman by the name of
Dave Holden was the composer of both my
films grow on edge in this recent film
off the menu and my experience in
working with him and collaborating with
him has been magnificent one of the
things you learn in independent
filmmaking is after your burned out
making the movie you get to an editing
room and you start putting staples that
are or examples that are available to
that alert of stick in for for cutting
purposes but you could never afford to
buy and in this particular case my first
movie and this movie Dave mandated if I
wanted to work with him I had to use
original musicians that essentially
encompassed the entire score of the film
and I was I used to be a musician and
for me that was just too good to be true
but along with that comes you know just
a burden for the filmmaker and for the
composer because everybody wants magic
and all the other composers that we
interviewed for the movie were were all
going to do it on a synthesizer you know
he goes you won't even tell differencing
the violins you know you won't be able
to tell the difference you know with the
scale of the orchestra
it'll just be totally believable and
that's true but when you bring in live
musicians there's just something that
happens especially if they're scoring it
to picture and that's what we did we
were very lucky to bring in some of the
best musicians in Los Angeles and and
then double them and make them look you
know the 16-piece orchestra sound like a
60-piece orchestra yeah it's an
interesting question about the
fundamentals of putting music in a movie
because movies require you to
you have a number of avenues you could
you could buy stock music needle drop is
what it's called and usually very
affordable in and you can pay extra to
have it for life and you know what your
burden is and since you're speaking to
not just the director but the producer
I'm gonna tell you that that is a huge
surprise to a lot of filmmakers because
they get up in the morning and go I
gotta have that track from the Rolling
Stones because the movies about this and
they got a song about this and that was
part of my pitch when I told my
investors and then he goes about trying
to get the song in the song he might get
a great deal on the song he might pay
I'm making this up right now 50 grand
for that song I'm talking about because
the filmmakers have a rapport with the
manager of the band or what have you the
problem is those songs that they're
buying all are licensed which means come
up a year they got a re divvy up funds
and I know a filmmaker you know that
made that mistake and put in a at least
six songs in his movie that are already
established songs but his not annually
is about a hundred seventy five grand
whether the movie makes money or not
he's got to pay it and one of the
luxuries I had is the the composer not
only was passion enough to want to be a
part of this project but he saw a life
at the other end where he could resell
the music and make it up there and it's
turned into a very profitable thing
actually more profitable for him than me
because he can license new music to
anybody sorry to play the devil's
advocate here but wouldn't the contract
say that he was purchasing it for this
amount in perpetuity or wouldn't there
be a time frame when he would need to
renew or say well this producer and
director who shall remain nameless
doesn't really you know he's not an
attorney and and he is so elated to get
the music
he probably I can only speculate you
know just like me
I'm not reading the fine print and the
outcome of it is is that he woke up in
the morning just with with a huge smack
in the face of something that he never
anticipated and to me like I mentioned
earlier you know with my last film I was
never expecting to get a bill from sag I
thought I'd paid all the people and the
movie hadn't even made half its money
back why am I getting billed for
residuals and ignorance you can call me
a total dope but I never was educated on
that component so I had to pull that
money which was over 20 grand out of my
own pocket because the funds just simply
aren't there and I learned a huge lesson
so now to your point I will put in my
budget you know a certain amount of
money aside for that twelve months later
moment where you got to go hey I got to
pay everybody you know another example
is is just understanding what you can't
do and what you can do and this goes to
music this what goes to sag actors and
this goes to getting excited about doing
a special screening and not knowing the
rules because if you take in money that
takes you to a different level and
forgive me for asking it in that way but
I wouldn't have known that either
I wouldn't know that you would need to
renew I mean a licensing fee or
something you'd be on the hook for
another year and well with music you you
know this is very interesting great
question because I believe and I'm sure
that what I'm suggesting happens all the
time
is you sell your movie to let's just say
hypothetically it's really well received
at Sundance you sell your movie to to a
big you know five star distribution
company and they go and recut it and
pull those expensive songs out because
they want to make money or conversely
the filmmaker pulls them out
so his film becomes more sellable
interesting and I have a friend who
actually my first screen around or my
first movie he sold his movie at
Sundance
and it was called Blue Valentine oh and
his name's Joey Curtis very nice guy
he co-wrote that movie but in his case
his next film was was everybody's
looking forward to it because his name
was equated with a movie that won at
Sundance and the outcome ova was is the
person that bought his next movie gave
him an extra half million dollars to
sweeten the pie put in better music
better sound effects so that also
happens as well that's that's a gold
mine in that case right great to know
yeah just all these little surprises
that you wouldn't expect and you don't
want to get that email on Monday morning
III think you know the film business is
a complicated business and you know you
read in the papers about bad blood
between distributors and filmmakers on
very very successful movies and you know
you see that I'm just making this up
that the guy who wrote a film that won
for you know four Oscars is still hasn't
made one royalty yet but meanwhile you
know everybody else got their hands out
yeah and it's creative financing
what-have-you but you know that doesn't
even affect me now because I'm not even
involved in that but it is something you
got to educate yourself
I had one filmmaker say to me that they
made sort of a $250,000 reel for
themselves that's what they considered
it at the end of the day and it became a
calling card and then it led to other
things but they were surprised to well I
think we all make movies as filmmakers
to help identify our next endeavor and
and in you project a positive review you
project a positive in some cases
financial success people are more
attracted to you that's why I found it
interesting in an earlier part of this
conversation where I said screenwriters
write great pieces but they insist on
directing it themselves when
in my mind if you're an unknown you're
more likely not going to see that as a
positive conclusion because who would
put their money into a director that's
never made a movie before
you